when that opportunity knocks and you can
become some successful in life you got
to push forward they may for everybody
you understand it's like everybody ain't
gonna be a star everybody ain't gonna be
T everybody ain't home deep what you are
just like when t plane came up t-pain
was the [ __ ] and everybody took his
auto-tune was nowhere she pay his music
career began in 1992 when he was
discovered by dr. Dre of NWA
he has since sold over 35 million albums
worldwide in 2012 after trip to Jamaica
he announced the conversion to the
Rastafari movement and a new alias new
clients he Snoop Dogg and here's my take
on his top 10 rules of success remember
what is my personal favorite and make
sure to stick around all the way to the
end become special bonus clips also a
Snoop Dogg is talking if we said
something that really means something to
you please leave in the comments and put
quotes around it so other people could
be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
I just I just go back to the time when I
was young and I didn't know what I
wanted to do in life
and once I found to grab the hold to
what I want to do which was this music
thing and I loved every minute of it
despite me not being able to make money
or have a career I had to believe in
myself and I want to say that to the
youngsters out there that's watching you
know believe anything that you believe
that but have the most believing it's
yourself whether it's being a doctor a
lawyer or your chemist or whatever it is
you have to believe yourself and then
once you believe the dream will come
true and the people will believe in you
that's what dreams are made of you have
to believe in it and then the dream can
come to life the advice that I would
give all of the rappers in the game is
to be original that's one thing about
you know when I came out originality was
a must
you had to sound like you you had to be
you you had to have your own everything
and I just feel like it's a lot of you
know mimicking going on because it's a
fad and everybody feels like what's hot
we're going to do what's hot we're going
to wrap the same way we're going to rap
over the same beats as opposed to being
different and dynamic the way it was
supposed to be in that's what we're
doing right now with this bush project
we put in something different out
there's not to bounce
it's a groove line yeah we got a groove
line with this record right it's a
groove that only you know if you grow
and you can you find it real quick but
if you only take your second to catch up
to it when that opportunity knocks and
you can become some successful in life
you got to push forward like even with
myself I had to make a decision when I
was a drug-dealing gangbanger am I going
to become a rapper and leave this behind
what I'm getting this money and you know
this ghetto superstardom
or do I really want to become a real
store and let that go and push it to the
limit and say I'm not going to eat I'm
not going to get no money I'm not going
to do number put my faith in this and I
did at 27 years later I can say alright
this was a great decision
my mother just to be far at peace within
yourself once you probably something
the energy that you get usually is
reflective and people make the energy
offer useful and that's what I've been
able to find then you know on the
negative energy pride of the young
lawyers here to grow man that project
positive and peaceful users but it still
has the energy of a young spirit so it's
always going to say well but it's just
finding yourself and being that could be
your thing yourself and happy that way
you could project you your respect to
you on the internet you know you can get
pulled into a whole lot of negative
energy I've done things while I put
pictures up and brief comments and do
not say something back and I end up
arguing with somebody on the internet
that I don't even know and I'm like you
didn't put me although out of my sketch
it was like it's just a part of knowing
you know your limitations are for an
employer goers and that people take you
out of your your frame of who you are
and I will never allow nobody to take me
out of the market that I'm supposed to
be and you know stand and never let me
show you swear to never never see me you
know deal with adversity with if I can't
deal with it but as you grow you loose
oh no Meah because it's called closing
the gap this is the gap when we start
this is the gap as you grow notice how
you grow and they don't so how do you
close the gap you've got to come back
down when you come back very low you got
to keep going up that's why closing the
gap got to be Tim catching up to you and
if they don't catch up you got to leave
them behind because you get to the point
now where you got to start cutting out
you know I'm saying it's like you can't
look back when you cut them out that
they meant to be there they gonna be ten
thousand yeah because I had to cut out
family members before me and my cousin
to ask a lot before well me and him fell
out it was like how do you fall I would
I taught you everything you know
I put you in again and you go against me
but that's what the laws of the game do
it puts you in a position to where
sometimes you have to have these types
of the situation to see who really posts
to be there
this day made for everybody you
understand it's like everybody ain't
gonna be install everybody ain't gonna
be everybody ain't gonna be what you are
it was 16 acres and she was rapping with
and out of m60 you them one and you can
go back and try to help all 60 of them
or guess what ain't none I'm going to
ever be you and I didn't done it many
times while I try to make [ __ ] stars
and rap donation took them on tour
damn that gave [ __ ] my shoes my
clothes my everything you could have all
I can't make you a star stars are born
they not made your I'm saying so it was
like if you want born one you can't make
one and you can't take your energy and
put it into somebody and make them what
you want I bet it cut a lot of [ __ ]
out that I really felt like you're not
mad I wonder how you doing you know what
I can't worry about how you doing
because if I worry about how you doing
that I'm going to miss a beat and I
might miss my lines on stage and they
might not want to pay me like they'll
entertain me
so indeed I got to get this money how
would you describe your body of work
prior to this transformation thanks
[Music]
people laugh at that but it really isn't
all that funny is it no it's not because
it was more or less the betrayal of what
I live and the life I lived in the
community that I came from I came from
selling drugs being involved in a gang
so most of my music was representative
of that but then once I became
successful I strayed away from that it
became a business and became Who I am
now so that's why the music is more
representative of Who I am today let me
ask you a question let's say that this
music that represents war a few you are
today is not as successful as the music
that represented how you were years ago
what doesn't bother me I'm not doing it
for you no financial reasons or
successful game it's more about where
I'm speaking to facts and issues that
you know like for example the gun issue
I have a song called no guns allowed
that speaks directly to the issues of
gun violence because I feel like
I think it would be nice if if that took
hold across the popular culture really
yeah and you know it starts with you you
got to be good you got to be the man in
the mirror to say you know what I'm
going to start with myself and through
example I believe that people will
follow I believe that the right thing
will be done because I'm going to used
to lead people in the wrong direction
now lead them in the right direction
but I respect the youngsters I respect
your movement because it's a young man's
game and I've always been like that
that's why they call me uncle snoop
because I've never disrespected him I've
always treated them as my nephew's even
if I didn't like this I never told them
I don't like it I tell them look maybe
you should try to be a little bit more
original and not all of the fat you know
because the fat is only a fact that rap
style is going to play out in a minute
but if it's yours is going to live on
forever
just like when t-pain came up t-pain was
just and everybody took his auto-tune
and went with it no where's t-pain even
got a where's his hair at he couldn't
because that's what the game dude again
[ __ ] you try take it takes from you you
know I'm saying it's like the originals
right I understand when you original you
gotta find ways to to diversify your
portfolio in other words meaning that I
always come back with some difference
and I'm Snoop Dogg at all the time but
I'm able to do this Dada Dada Dada Dada
net to where it finally comes back to
the point to where I started in 1992 was
my thing and I'm still on the radio
talking to you about an album I got
coming out that's relevant the best
advice I can give you is go make some
noise you know these emcees right here
was doing a thing before I got bored and
that's what made it easy for me to get
on with it I don't have to teach them
how to be who they are you got to find
out who you are and be the best at that
and once you master that who you are
being being great at that basically
somebody like myself will come across
you and be able to gated opportunity you
just may make it on your own some stars
are born you know you don't need people
like me to make you when you're born
star so I just want to inspire those out
there that watching what we doing seeing
what we're doing just look at the
positivity of what we're doing you have
to practice over the years I wasn't
great in the beginning I was I and you
know I got cool and then I got do it and
I got better and they're not that great
those are steps to becoming great a lot
of people are willing to
to take those steps it takes ten years
that something continues to become great
ne and I stuck with it's a ten year
straight before I had a record deal
before I had money before I had lights
and camera before I had you know people
want to sit down interview me so uh
Snoop are you ready to play with the
snow I'm ready to get this money yeah
[Applause]
honestly if you get one one question and
if you get it correctly you would you
get 50,000 if you happen not to answer
it you'll get 25,000 anyway so what you
play trivia much you flirt yeah it is
well you've got one expert to help you
is name is Ken Jennings he's the duck
trivia guy of all time and you got on
the lifelines as well so if you're
already snoop we're going to go for it
right now
stay ready so I gotta get ready okay
fine let's play this
okay so here it is in the 2009 superhero
film Watchmen which characters costume
physically includes a mess decorated
with a flick
the comedian dr. Manhattan neidell or
Russia
man I've seen them while we corn I fell
asleep on tell me that you fell asleep
you got fifty thousand riding on this ah
watch me which characters costume
physically includes the best anybody
wearing a mask if you remember I will
remember him wearing a mask or remember
to move the bigs in his luck yeah well
I'll remember his name dr. Manhattan
night out or Russia
can i actaully you want to ask the
audience positively yes let it go
audience in the 2009 superhero film
Watchmen which characters costume
physically includes a mess decorated
with in blood legit the comedian dr.
Manhattan night owl or Rorschach on your
key bed both a I know what it is
[Applause]
professor Ross jacket before the
audience had said to answer well while
the folding was going on you said to me
you think you know who it is I thought
it was Ben because when I was sleeping I
kept hearing that name
which have been a very exciting movie
that's every why do you think it's
project the audience tinkles Ross we're
going to make it a final n so when you
get this please do what final answer
will be D Rorschach yes
[Applause]
okay
Oh
I
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because John Michael
Mousasi asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you are going to
profile next leave in the comments below
I will see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you learn
today from Snoop Dogg's that really
resonated with you what was the most
important lesson that you're going to
take from this please leave it in the
comments I'm curious to find out finally
want to give a quick shout out to best
you pro thank you so much man for
picking up a top of my book and tweeting
out that awesome picture as well I
really really really really appreciate
it so thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
my kids success will be doing the
otherwise you would have them do unto
you
be respectful make good music stay true
to who you want on be different be a
honey be original and I believe those
things like their will give you
longevity they'll give you a long time
to do what you doing because that
creates a lane of peace prosperity
respect and love and that will be
honored by time and your legacy will be
evaluated in due time I got to ask you
did you ever meet and spend any time
with Michael Jackson yeah me and my got
a phone again I don't know if it ever
came out I'm telling you right now did
not because I would already known that I
did when to that it was a some sort of
project he was doing and what was crazy
was right he called me so to hear his
voice on the phone he was like hey it's
Michael I'm like well Faneca he's like
well first of all my mom says that you
look like someone of my family we could
be related that's cool yes you name it
oh right I have this particular truck
and I want you to sing on it and you
know just do whatever you whatever you
want to do well i curl my line I'll get
back at you car and that was a
conversation so wrong again today I went
to work you know I went all night
talking come on road you you know I was
infatuated when I hung up I was like
looking a wall just on the phone like
Justin no not you man no no joke I think
Michael did you ever see him in person
yeah we it was a dual and Christian
Audigier he had the clothing line I
forgot when Heidi yes yeah yes hell a
document that yeah yeah it was a baby he
was a boss he and he was been like three
four hundred thousand dollars to have
you come perform like three songs if
he'd me Michael
accident whoever else whoever else and
Michael Jackson trailer were right next
to mine and was blowing like a broke
stove and Mike open the curtain and
looked always him nice new see what is
I'm like no thank you
alrighty so what we're gonna do right
now big one let's go ahead and blend
them with a instrument of his own so we
can go ahead and get something live from
Snoop Dogg up in here you remember just
right here dawg yeah
you want something notice I'm hold on
this man I wanted gin and juice with so
much drama in the LBC it's kind of hard
me and Snoop people double G but I
somehow someway keep coming up with
funky funky funky funky with so much
drama in the LBC you're kind of hard
being it's your people GG but I somehow
someway keep coming up with funky ass
hits like every single day
may I kick a little pop up of the G and
make a few games as a breeze through
it's 2:00 in the morning and the party
still jumping cuz my mom ain't home I
got the chickens in this getting it on
and they ain't leaving till 6:00 and the
moment so what you want to do I got a
pocketful up and big boy he got thrown
to Mike who knows to go but we don't
love it
so we will go out fishin gzip frees up
for what second now bouncing it
I put the radio version of that pine is
every it really is bad omen
yes time and we just rolling down the
street smoking smoking smoking sipping
on Jenna goes to lay back with my mind
on my money now and then I've got me
freaking jeans
everybody got beat up put the ain't
shifting it now decide to hit happens
all the time
you got to get yours big I got a good
mind so everything is fine when you
listen to 92.3 not point but the real
for me nobody goes up we'll see I come
off the dome get you cracking they're
rapping and all along to sit back relax
let me show you how I posed to be I'll
do it see every day 92 3 C I'm the
realtor you fill it you can't push punk
ass OPP goes up with you on the top of
the bus and Captain Crunch what I eat
for breakfast then I get my mind right
jumpin my lenses in a head on the trip
just to get my quick and say what up to
big boy what off crap alright man we
gotta go with this right now
for that we gotta go with these knees
right huh alright here we go
[Music]
okay iliza to write it down don't go
here this with the one a bit of God they
should serve me up a little bit right
stop it stop it
hopping like a rabbit when I think the
Liberals you know I got the head on the
head they beckon the country famous
there I'm thinking about the hidden
impending whale now how can I make my
quick and how can I make this bucket
straight flick that trip I got agita
Kovac scripts at the tip around the
corner and now I'm onna your permission
question upon a stone it's no joke he's
all with the caviar in the back of the
limo lord mo business is real I'm
breaking y'all sound like you've and a
homely clear chill so the next episode
I'll make money and I really don't love
again you the truth
I'll open the coat I used to tell no one
I used to shoot homework not one mate
hit every single day and quickly my
homie the VD doctors ready go lay back
in the cut young plus before you get
shot its 187 on y'all and the cops tell
us I was that I was before you all for
just a
I'm getting hot yes indeed his big boys
on the Mikey bug Bogota he hands up a
little to the beat that's me break it
down for you to with so vicious please
spit that breath I got to get this right
I got to hit that trap I got to hit that
lick I got to get that grip I got a tip
that drink I got to make that move I got
a boat like I gotta lay low somehow to
West Coast go big boys when I bang on
the bank job Snoop Dogg came to I heard
a deep and quick I think you better let
me get a verse on let's keep it cool
keep it Paul keep that dog you defending
you break lobby you come through you
come hard you come boss so Gulf Dakota
tips the ER doctor not a real 96 week
later pop the Normandy all right